what's up you guys it's Wednesday if you
hear the noise in the background that's
long a long I thought they were nothing
I've got too long crews hour-long crew
and then the and then the neighborhood a
neighborhood long come on out yeah yeah
so we can't stop them yeah well at least
it's better than early because I guess
our lawn crew was here earlier they were
like right outside the window it's like
really really loud okay we're sit not
that YouTube paid the membership the
membership thing I don't know how long
it's gonna take because it does have a
little message it's like you know
obviously it needs to go through a
review to make sure your perks are fine
and everything and they're like well
we're behind because YouTube is
short-staffed obviously like everywhere
is so they're like it might take longer
than it was so I don't know like when
it's gonna go right online but it would
be good if I don't know like I'm
thinking about kind of perks I mean we
already do a lot of videos I guess we
could do like shorter Members Only
videos although for Christ's sake we
might like run out of [ __ ] to talk about
yeah that hasn't happened so far
we um you don't have to you can do
Members Only live streams you can do
Members Only chats you can do don't
really have enough members to worry
about that at this point yes I'm just
saying well yeah but to set it up you
have to say like what the perks are
gonna be okay
um you could do like Members Only like
community posts [ __ ] like that
I don't think we should do Members Only
live streams that we do a live stream is
you should it should be for everybody
yeah yeah because that a waste of time
you didn't have two people on it yeah
right they get everybody there at once
it's crazy I'm just saying that's those
are like examples of what they think
like you can get four perks yeah I think
the bottom rung rung on the payment will
probably be like $1.99 $2.99 399
something like that will be the
entry-level then they'll be like a $5
payment and they'll be like a $20.00 a
month payment run yeah something like
that
that's probably what you can expect
we'll probably start off pretty basic
first that's what yeah cuz I just kind
of want to get it up there and then
worry about ya tweaking it later just
like I did with the patreon it's like
you know what I mean and it'll be a good
option you know cuz it doesn't really
like
does anything to do it'll just be a good
option for people that don't want to go
through patreon or whatever reason perks
are probably like the arm patreon though
that's probably I'll probably like give
like early access just like I do the
patrons cuz you know page on patreon
people usually get to see the stuff like
a day ahead I post everything like a day
ahead for them yeah remember that dude
from that movie I said I want to see him
be Flash Gordon yeah but it was his name
his name's Bowser or monster boss or
Robert
robb maus or something like that it was
two A's in it I found him I sent him a
message I said man if I could I'd like
to move it I like to I liked your movie
I saw you jump out at [ __ ] airplane
there [ __ ] ninety seventeen and I want
to see is like in Flash Gordon
you know you'd make an awesome flash
court well see he says yeah he needs be
Flash Gordon you're the first well the
first thing that when he took off the
skin mask I was kind of like man that
dude's face looks just like yeah what I
imagine Flash Gordon would look like
based on a damn Comics the old 1930 yeah
he looks like he stepped out of the
1920's 1930's that's what i thought
maybe it was the hair style like I'm not
really sure it was that close curly yeah
that's weak on his pages too yeah he's
got that he looks like a damn statue
outside the right stock drama statues
and looks just like that flick like
that's exactly what it looks like yeah
but yeah they'd have to he'd have to
like do I don't know he talked some in
the dare but I couldn't tell if he had a
German accent I wasn't aware of you know
I'm in heaven German but he didn't talk
much in it so I wasn't really sure and
he might have been overdubbed for all I
know I don't think he did it didn't
matter yes so I don't know if he has
like a German accent but to play Flash
Gordon I guess you'd have to be like
super American or whatever I don't know
I don't think so
maybe not no I mean like you'd have to
like talk like you were you could fake
that's in America you just yeah it has
to be like transatlantic yeah it's
because Europeans seem to do American
accents much better than Americans do
European accents I'm not really sure why
that is there's so many different
American accents I've heard bad ones
though - yeah I've heard it's be be
Lister and see Lister British accents
tried to America
[ __ ] and it's kind of strange
hilariously but you know nine times out
of ten though a lot of times like when I
see an actor in a movie and I don't even
think about it like they're playing an
American and then later if I find out
they were a Brit and it's like kind of
blows my mind a little bit um you know
it's only you only notice it when you
notice it well a lot of ones that can
real good at it like the guys off the
wok and did they live here yeah so well
they have to live here yeah for because
you know what I mean because yeah after
a few years you can actually pick up an
accent anyway most people do yes just
because you're surrounded by a mean [ __ ]
I didn't even live in the UK that long
but I've noticed that I mean what I came
back like people said that I talked to
kind of funny I used to make her talk
talk say something say potato yeah they
just they thought that was hilarious and
not and I don't like it made me really
uncomfortable like I know there I know
they were just like being nice and stuff
but they were just like listen to her
talk she said tomato just like stop me I
know it's like this I'm like you guys
are so mean they are they are good what
else is going on um oh yeah so last
night we decided like after we watched
our third matinee movie we decided we
were gonna re-watch the art of
self-defense
yeah you guys remember we saw like in
the theater like back when it came out
and we it's really weird because I
really loved cuz I loved that kind of
like deadpan dark humor I thought he was
gonna hate it
I [ __ ] loved it when we were watching
it like I'm sitting there going man he's
gonna hate this movie but he liked it
like surprisingly well it's not it's not
humor man that's just [ __ ] real yeah
looking at humor exactly okay you guys
go back this we saw that after I think
we did the [ __ ] oh [ __ ] show
didn't we do it I think now I'm pretty
sure we thought before that just we saw
I mean like a while back cuz I'd already
known all about Bushido or [ __ ] oh
and I'm knew all about count Dante and
the black dragon fighting society I had
friend like I said before you know my
friends ninja gym and my [ __ ] step
brother Billy and all that [ __ ]
martial arts [ __ ] when I was a kid
so I knew all about a lot of the stuff
you know and to see it up on the screen
and I think we it's we didn't we see
Cobra Kai nobody saw Cobra Kai and that
was after it takes every aspect of
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh and [ __ ] brings
it to light and maybe slide a bit but
not in like but not a funny Burt and fun
it's yeah they're bad it's not really
even that exaggerated no it's not as
that a bunch of murders happen oh yeah
that part's a bit exaggerated
exaggerated that's not that exaggerated
because count Dante [ __ ] and you know
heat set off some bombs and [ __ ] okay
a bank I forgot about one of his guys
got killed by another gang a [ __ ]
with a sword with a sword from karate
dojo spike each other in Chicago so it
they're weird dojos like this okay I
forgotten all about yeah so that's why I
was saying this is not a joke yeah it
[ __ ] like that did happen yeah if you
guys want to see some [ __ ] badass foot
see the art of self-defense yeah it's on
xbox had it yeah I think it was to not
399 yeah or 299 is it was that it came
out of well we reviewed it for the
matinee show like a long time ago when
it was out in the theater and I feel
like it didn't get a lot of attention
nobody noticed it like it seemed like
III read some reviews of it like on AV
Club and said they they really liked it
but I feel like it kind of went under
the radar a little bit I think it only
played here for like a week or so I
loved it it started off kind of slow I
wasn't sure I was gonna like it it
starts off the super beta main character
he's just like a beta made of the
Eisenberg beautiful actor I mean the
[ __ ] pitiful okay
terrible that's how you can't stand it
and and he gets his ass beat by a
[ __ ] roving gang of motorcycle dudes
they beat his ass and he tries to man up
he goes buys a gun but then said but
then sees a dojo and sees the cria does
it wise what way he's going through his
waiting period and he joins the second
dojo
alright forgets all about the gun and
vegan
say and that's what they call him okay
since a turns this total tries to turn
this total beta [ __ ] male into a into
an alpha male or something there tries
to turn him into a hero but now really
you know I mean [ __ ] it minute then
it goes into like inner dojo politics
and money and I don't want to spoil it
yeah I really enjoyed the movie not
knowing much about it you know just
going into it blind yeah because we had
just seen the trailer and I said that
looks kind of funny yeah and like I said
it's a it surprised me that you liked it
so much because it's more my kind of
humor later or it reminded me a little
bit of like a Coen Brothers movie but
not quite cuz it's a lot more like
deadpan than that ya know it it's
because there's two groups in the movie
beta beta males okay and their humor and
[ __ ] this basically alpha male or
Sigma male criminals and their humor and
it's not quite humor yes more kind of
like evil but it is kind of fun just
well the situations are funny and also
kind of horrifying yeah it ain't funny
[ __ ] happens you're like what the [ __ ]
but then it makes sense later yeah
there's a lot of mystery in the movie
you don't find out till later what what
this dojo is all about I can't spoil it
just go watch I mean the end of this was
like the [ __ ] best yeah and I got a
sip and go wait a minute hold on does
that mean does that mean that this did
yeah that's what that [ __ ] means yeah
I want to buy it on blu-ray it was it it
was actually funnier the second time I
saw it because since I already knew what
the story was and like I could kind of
pay attention more to like all the
little subtleties and [ __ ] but it's just
like when it's almost kind of like
making fun of it's not really making I
really making fun of things it's yeah
it's kind of making fun of like the
performance of this over-the-top like
alpha male yeah yeah it's making fun of
that
but not really it is it is it is but
it's not you know I don't know in a
strange way it's kind of hard for me to
put it's true yeah what they're talking
about is true there were there were
dudes like that yeah really it was not
so much the alpha male [ __ ] what it was
is it was the Charlatans ism yeah you
know I mean [ __ ] oh it was [ __ ]
they're talking about that
how many charlatans and [ __ ] maniacs
there were in the [ __ ] crying they're
out there just like taking advantage of
people's weaknesses where's is in fear
and then doing all kinds of weird and
making [ __ ] up and the the belt colors
and how their order is the correct order
nobody else's orders their core their
order of belt progression is the best
and that then you find out later that
well I don't want to put this boy at it
so it kind of comes across see like the
whole cult like meant that culture is
very very cultists very corrupt but in
the end honor was restored yeah I
remember I remember we saw this in the
theater and like that end that scene
near the end you know what saying I'm
talking about I'm not going to spoil it
I [ __ ] busted out laughs yeah it was
just one of the funniest things there
but it was almost kind of like horror it
was diet
I like that kind of few people were
dying to commit murders and [ __ ] [ __ ]
see it was just like it's just I laughed
at I liked it because the whole story
everybody in the story pretty much which
some sociopaths pretty much dancing
the good guys and the bad guys were all
[ __ ] sociopath so if there were no
real good everything was just great
yeah but it is a deep story it's yes
it's not like a heavy story and it is
and I don't know it's a very strange
very mythological it's very not it's
very much kind of like and it in in the
end in the end the honor of [ __ ]
karate is saved
yeah and honor of the dojo is restored
you'll see just got to see it it's a and
it's not it's not a comedy like airplane
or in
like I said it's very very wacky car
eyes not varied what's a dark comedy
almost and very dark yeah almost almost
horror but you bust up [ __ ] laughing
because it's just the absurdity yeah I
don't even know what genre I would call
it like it I think it's reality it's
usually marketed as a comedy which it is
because it's funny but it's not the
funny ha-ha kind of fun yeah some of the
[ __ ] that's going on miss dojo there's
there's like analogies to the US Army
too and religion their religious analogy
analogies also corporate and the
corporate worlds actually talked about -
yeah what the dude does it is job it's
just the movies of masterpiece I'm so
say some of those some of those scenes
with him what at work like talking is
doing spoiled not touching the movie is
a [ __ ] masterpiece this is the second
time I saw it noses I liked it even more
I liked it better I got the man I got to
buy this [ __ ] on blu-ray
it was just like it was much funnier
than I remember yeah because the first
time I saw it I'd seen the trailer and I
wasn't really sure I said well it looks
like a dark comedy which I like but I
wasn't really sure what was gonna happen
and like it's a very like genre list
type of movie like you can't really put
your finger on what you're slightly
weird slice-of-life no not really
yeah kind of that's what I mean you'd
ever see bethe [ __ ] male just pitiful
pitiful dude endeavours to become a real
man that's really what the [ __ ] Camus is
about and I should leave it that I don't
leave it that yeah I'm glad we saw it
again we were just kind of like [ __ ]
around cause like I said it was still
early like we finished watching our
third matinee movie and we were just
like messing around and tom was like
scrolling through all the new releases
and he's like oh art of self-defense
again it's like cuz I don't even
remember we saw at the theater but and
the rental gives you Chevy two hours
might watch that [ __ ] again
that [ __ ] was [ __ ] good I thought you
got like two weeks does it I think he's
you have two weeks to you can watch it
now once you watch it I think it no and
then it goes nice I think it 48 hours
yeah I think when you first run it
before you watch it if you
two weeks and then once you watch it I
think it gives you 48 hours or so this
is what I want on blu-ray if anybody
wants to gift me ya like it just really
surprised me that you really it's just
like it kind of surprised me that you
really liked the dead don't die because
I didn't think you'd be in the lake Jim
Jarmusch which is that the zombie one
that weird zombie one with [ __ ] Bill
Murray and like [ __ ] yeah like that way
yeah we saw that twice that yeah yeah
yeah a lot of people hate oh no it was
good
I can see why people hated it because
it's just a tongue-in-cheek
[ __ ] cuz the tone of it was very yeah
I liked it weird but yeah I kind of dug
I liked Jim Jim that movie wasn't taking
herself seriously though that movie was
[ __ ] that movie was [ __ ] with you
yeah yeah well like I said it's geoff
chalmers yes is that the same director
that did did now but okay you directed
this one oh [ __ ] man i can't remember so
it was a writer director I think the
same guy right at that directed it he
wrote a masterpiece this is if I don't
like I said I liked it I liked it a lot
better than a second yeah just like all
this [ __ ] [ __ ] I was just thinking of
the [ __ ] Ishita cam and [ __ ] and
[ __ ] uh yeah you're back it wasn't so
I gonna see the kid things yeah yeah and
being a ninja like sneaking around
backyard or like high knows like it's
black for sure whoever wrote this did
their research on the [ __ ] the black
dragon fighting society on a sheet of
Kim and I'll [ __ ] count Dante and
then they were [ __ ] lunatics yeah
they were [ __ ] lunatics this almost
comes across like a weird like deadpan
dark comedy version of the kid like a
little bit kinda a little bit mad I
could just well like I said you know
[ __ ] known about known about count on
tears like notice that [ __ ] happen that
[ __ ] probably did happen and like you
said we do just that it I forgot that
like he had he had like [ __ ] tree a
rod bombed those [ __ ] be bombed and
and robbery back to yeah and that guy
getting killed with the sword and the
Fojo yeah and he died of [ __ ] taking
drugs yeah taking drugs but he he he was
doing what Bruce Lee wanted to do yeah
you know that was the
that was the beginning of the [ __ ]
coup but a concept them going there and
actually beating the [ __ ] [ __ ] out
each other yeah in a dojo then and they
you know that's what they're doing in
this one the night class yeah like like
Fight Club yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
funny like I said I guess you have to
have a specific way that a sense of
humor 299 399 something like that
well-spent man yeah I mean what else
he's kind of stuck at home they're gonna
probably run it out of stuff to watch at
this point I'm not as I'm still like
[ __ ] behind that a bunch of stuff and
behind out a bunch of books and projects
and other crap too you got anything else
you want to discuss no that's okay I
don't think I have anything else I won't
discuss either so we're gonna wrap this
up for Wednesday tastes stay safe and
healthy out there we'll talk to you
again tomorrow